let's go next to our caller from the
nine seven eight area code who's calling
today from 978 hi can you hear me yes I
can't who's this my name is mark I live
in Framingham great and Mark please just
keep the phone you're coming in shot out
of a cannon very very hot just try to
either talk a little more quietly or
maybe keep that you had the mouthpiece a
little further from your mouth okay in
some sense all right well first I'd like
to know what do you think makes Trump in
anomaly because you've said that you
think Trump is just uniquely bad
considering that Bush invaded nations
that were still in after decades against
international law even though the UN
said there weren't weapons of mass
destruction how is Trump any more of a
corrupt evil gangster than Bush was
that's my first question so first we
have a sort of category error which is
you are it sounds like you're saying
let's supply the sort of foreign policy
standards that we would apply to typical
neo-cons to Donald Trump in order to
evaluate them against each other and
what I would assert is that we're
dealing with category differences Donald
Trump is bad in a way that is very
different than how george w bush was bad
and of course if you're looking for
someone to defend george w bush that's
certainly not going to be me we spent
you know the the greater part of Bush's
presidency pointing out all of the ways
in which Bush was bad Don Donald Trump
is bad in a in a different way and I'll
give you one example that I think is
relevant george w bush's foreign policy
is the disgusting neocon foreign policy
of people like john bolton and you know
Wolfowitz and rumsfeld and so on and so
forth and that's absolutely horrible but
george w bush would not have screwed up
coronavirus the way Donald Trump did and
this is not praise of Bush and Bush it
was a disaster on Katrina mostly for
different reasons but even someone as
uniquely horrible as
bush from the foreign policy perspective
would not have messed this up in the way
that Donald Trump did george w bush made
the wrong foreign policy decisions with
iraq but he didn't ruin so many of our
long-standing alliances and get the
united states to be essentially ignored
in large swaths of the global decisions
that have to be made so I just think
that there's a category difference the
ways in which I criticize Bush are
different fundamentally than the ways in
which Trump has been an embarrassing
failure all right well well but what do
you don't arresting that also of the NSA
and Patriot and the Patriot Act by Bush
were also things that were also evil
examples of domestic policy as well yet
but both of those contained horrible
provisions yes I agree with that okay
and my last question which is just a
total irrelevant to the first two I know
you're a big chess player if someone
were trying to get into chess what
resources do you think would be best for
a beginner I I would just go on YouTube
and just google chess for beginners and
you'll find hundreds of hours of simple
videos just getting people introduced to
the concepts and then also Lee chess org
slash practice has a bunch of free
resources for just starting to learn the
basics okay thank you
all right great appreciate the phone
call thank you so much